- Welcome back.
We are here with the creators
and stars of the new movie,
Lisa Frankenstein,
Cole Sprouse, Zelda Williams,
Diablo Cody and Kathryn Newton.
The new movie features a young woman
who much like the
original Dr. Frankenstein
brings a creation to life using science.
In honor of the new movie and
all monster movies out there
it's time for a game
called Monster Mashup.
♪ Monster Mashup ♪
Alright, so Diablo kindly agreed to host.
Take it away, Diablo.
- Thank you, Kelly.
I feel like Ryan Seacrest right now.
- Nice.
- This is very exciting
for me to be hosting.
In this game, I will give
clues that have to do
with famous monster
movies, actors, and so on.
If you know the answer,
hit your button and answer,
and if you're wrong, the
other team can steal.
- Okay.
- The teams are Zelda and Cole
playing for the left side of the audience.
And Kelly and Kathryn playing
from the right side of the audience.
(audience cheering)
- I like my team.
- Yeah.
- I see, I see who's competitive here.
The winner will earn a
Lisa Frankenstein prize
for their side.
So let's go.
- Okay.
- Is it a puppy?
- Yeah.
- What do we win? A puppy.
- Okay.
- All right.
- First question.
In John Krasinski's movie, A Quiet Place.
(button beeping)
Mostly...
- Kathryn.
- Oh here we go. No...
- That's what they said.
They said you could click it early.
- No. What's the answer?
I don't know yet. The
question has not been said.
(audience laughing)
(bell sound)
- It sounds like we can steal.
- I think they get to steal, I'm sorry.
- What? No.
- I think that's how it works.
No, you have to, you can
interrupt the question,
but then you have to
know the answer by then.
So let's just say.
- Yeah.
- Emily Blunt.
(bell sounds)
(Kelly screaming)
- Okay.
- What? No.
- Oh my God.
(audience cheering)
- No way.
- We just let you.
- Oh yeah.
(indistinct conversations)
- The house always wins, huh?
- I just.
(overlapping conversation)
- No. No.
- We get to steal.
- That's not, she's
literally the only person
I can remember in the movie.
Look.
- Wow.
- Let's just take it. We're gonna move on.
- Next question.
The monster in this movie
was Bradley Whitford and his family.
The title is also what you ...
Yes, Zelda.
- Get Out.
- That's right.
(bell sounds)
(audience cheering)
- See what happened when you play fair?
- We would have gotten that.
- That is messed up movie.
- We would had that. That was all you.
- I love Bradley Whitford, I'm sorry.
- Good.
- Let's go.
- I'm too.
- God.
- Next question.
- Okay.
- In the movie monster,
a sex worker in Florida
became a serial killer.
The film won an Academy
Award for what lead actress?
(beep sound)
- Charlize Theron.
- Yes.
(bell sound)
(audience cheering)
(overlapping conversation)
- So good.
- Yeah. Yeah.
You put that away.
- Next question.
In what movie were the
humans hunting a monster
in the ocean only to discover
that to their dismay,
they were going to need a bigger boat.
- Oh, I did it first, Jaws.
- What about you? Good, you're right.
- I was like, I did it. I'm so knowable.
(audience cheering)
- Bigger boat.
- Is this a tie?
I think it's.
- That's a tie.
- All right. Next question.
This musical story featured
a monster that fed on human
(beep sound)
- Rocky Horror Picture Show.
- No, no.
- No.
(buzzer sound)
- What?
- No.
- It's a.
- A Little Shop of Horrors.
- shop of Horrors.
- But we get to steal it.
- Yeah, that's why I'm stealing it.
I'm stealing it.
- But I said it.
- No, but yeah.
(overlapping conversation)
- But, yeah, I said the same time.
(bell sound)
- Thank you.
(all laughing)
(audience cheering)
- Next question.
- Keep me quiet.
- This movie was based on
a show, a cartoon actually,
in which a bunch of meddling kids.
(beep sound)
- Scooby Do.
- Scoobert-Dobert Do.
(audience cheering)
(tapping sounds)
- Oops.
- Next question.
In what movie did two characters played
by John Goodman and Billy Crystal
team up to capture the
screams of children.
(beeping sounds)
- Monsters Inc.
- That is correct.
(bell sounds)
(audience cheering)
- It was good.
- That was good.
- We got this. We got this.
- Okay.
(overlapping conversations)
- Okay, so that's good to remember.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- In what monster movie did
an escape circus performer
wait in a storm drain?
(beep sounds)
- IT.
- That's right.
(bell sounds)
(audience cheering)
- My mind was blown.
My mind was blown.
(audience cheering)
- Is that a tie?
(air horn sounds)
- I think we're tied up.
- Just say that.
I don't think it was
affiliated with a circus. Okay.
I'm looking at record that air horn means
we have to move on to the last question.
- If that was an alien, you're correct.
- In what movie did Meryl
Streep and Goldie Hawn.
- Oh my God.
Death Becomes Her
(both cheering)
(bell sounds)
(audience cheering)
One with the Meryl Streep.
(air horn sounds)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
- Thank you sir, thank you
for playing. Nice work.
Thank you, great job.
Great job, great job.
(indistinct conversations)
- Oh my gosh.
- Alright.
You are welcome anytime to
be my teammate in a game.
You are so fun.
And everyone in the audience is a winner
because it's my show and I say so.
(audience cheering)
- Courtesy of Focus Features,
you're all going home
with a pair of tickets
to see Lisa Frankenstein!
(audience cheering)
And everybody watching out
to see Lisa Frankenstein
in theaters this Friday.